how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and everything relating to the mcu and
today we have kind of
a spoilery video and of course it's
about the one division series coming to
disney plus
this year so sometime within the next
two months we'll get the release of the
one division series and we'll know
everything but until then if you were
trying to avoid any and all spoilers
you've been warned and this isn't
exactly
that big of a surprise it's something
that most of us have thought for a while
now we've heard reports we've heard
rumors and today it's basically
confirmed
that quicksilver pedro maximoff the
brother of wanda maximoff aka the
scarlet witch
will be returning to the mcu in at least
one
episode of the wanda vision series and
as i mentioned we have some pretty solid
evidence of this today so we're gonna
break down everything you need to know
but first
big congratulations to youtube user
gabriel sharp knack for being the winner
of the spider-man imposter funko pop
giveaway just email me in the email in
my description and i'll get you your
prize and for the rest of you we have
some big
holiday giveaways coming up so be sure
to subscribe so you can enter i'll
announce them in my next video
so in a world and tv series where wanda
is going to be
bending realities around her it makes
sense that her brother would make an
appearance
after all she did manage to bring her
lover vision back to life so it would
only make sense for her to bring her
brother back as well
now we have heard about quicksilver
returning before there was a leaked
audition tape
of a young boy auditioning for the role
of one of wanda and vision's kids
and in this leaked audition tape they
mention their uncle
and as far as we're concerned vision
doesn't really have any brothers or
sisters since he was an android that was
created so they can really only be
talking about quicksilver
but if that wasn't evidence enough today
we have some pretty big evidence
yesterday the instagram account sir lent
pops posted to their instagram account
some news about the upcoming emerald
city comic con and in their post they
announced that there's an upcoming
two-pack one division funko pop
including vision
and quicksilver now this instagram
account is
pretty much 100 accurate when it comes
to pre-releases of funko pops their
leaks are usually 100 spot on
which leads us to believe that this leak
is indeed true which means marvel
studios has made a new
quicksilver funko pop for the one
division series that is coming out
which can only really mean one thing
quicksilver will be
returning now again in a show where we
have a very powerful witch who could
basically bend reality to what she wants
it to be
it doesn't surprise us that much that
quicksilver is returning but the
question is how exactly will he return
and
will it be permanent now aaron taylor
johnson still does have some projects
left on his contract for marvel studios
so if he pops up
it won't be that big of a surprise
however let's not forget that it has
been confirmed that evan peters
is going to be on the one division
series as well now for those who may not
know evan peters played quicksilver
in the fox x-men universe and this kind
of makes you wonder what marvel studios
is doing
at first we did not really think that
evan peters would return as a different
version
of quicksilver in the marvel cinematic
universe why would marvel bring back
evan peters quicksilver when aaron
taylor johnson's quicksilver is the
actual brother of wanda in the mcu
that's what everybody was thinking at
least until a couple of weeks ago
it was announced and confirmed that
jamie foxx will be reprising his role as
electro but he will be in the marvel
cinematic universe and spider-man 3.
so they're taking a character that
existed outside of the mcu
just like evan peters quicksilver and
bringing him
into the mcu so although we'd like to
believe that aaron taylor johnson's
quicksilver is going to be the one
returning it could in fact be evan
peters quicksilver
after all the one division show is going
to lead into the multiverse of madness
and anything is possible in the
multiverse including
alternate versions of different
characters however if it is aaron taylor
johnson we have to wonder how long he'll
be back for and if he's going to
actually be brought back to life or will
it just exist in a fake reality that
wanda may create
if i find out more i'll definitely let
you know so be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest mcu
videos and let me know what you think is
going to happen in the comments down
below do you think it's going to be evan
peters's quicksilver or do you think
we'll see aaron taylor johnson's
quicksilver
which would you like to see happen which
do you prefer let me know what you think
in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof